[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAN AHARON: Hi, everyone.
I'm pleased to be here with you.
I hope you're having an
awesome Google Cloud Next.
I'm here to talk to you about
something that I'm personally
very excited about,
and we at Google
are very excited about, which
is conversational applications,
which includes Bots,
and I hope you're
as excited as me at the
beginning of the session,
or if not, by the end of it.
Here we're going
to introduce API.AI
to you guys, which is a
tool probably many of you
are familiar with.
It's our Bot application
development platform
that we acquired last year.
And we're also going
to go beyond the basics
and show you guys a little
bit more tips and tricks.
So you're going to hear from
a couple people, Cornelius
and Petr, that have
been using API.AI,
and they're going to
share some of the lessons
that they've learned while
building conversational Bots.
So, this is one of
three different sessions
we have on this topic of
conversational applications.
We had one yesterday
which focused
on cloud functions and
surveillance and architecture
to serve conversational
applications.
We're now doing
the middle session
that you see on the slide.
And then, following after
me, Brad and Guilliame
are going to show you how
to extend Google assistant
with actions on Google.
So, what is a conversational
agent platform?
We'll just go through this
quickly, probably a lot of you
already know, but,
basically what it does
is it takes natural
language and it turns it
into structured data
that you can then
use in your applications.
So, for example,
if a user orders
a pizza and says what
ingredients it has,
the software will turn that
into structured data which
says what's exactly inside
the pizza, what type it is,
and then you can
actually act on it.
What it doesn't do
is, it doesn't really
understand your domain
and your vertical
until you actually
teach it and train it.
You can give training
examples that
explain exactly what to do.
And, it also doesn't
do any fulfillment.
It's not actually
going to bake a pizza
and deliver it for
you, unfortunately.
That would be nice.
But, the good thing is you're
here at Google Cloud Next,
you've probably been
to a bunch of sessions.
Most of this
conference is about how
to fulfill the back-end
of your application,
and we think Google Cloud
Platform is a great way
to do that.
So, it's a very good
complement to API.AI
And then, specifically,
we're very proud of API.AI,
we think it's pretty
distinctive in the space.
A few of the important
benefits that API.AI
has that it is an
end-to-end suite,
it really combines a bunch
of different elements
that you need for building
compositional applications.
It doesn't just do natural
language understanding, or just
one component.
It can get pretty
smart very quickly.
You're going to
see that later on.
I'm going to attempt to do
something that's probably very
risky, and not very wise of me.
I'm going to try and
build in front of you,
from scratch, a whole new
conversational application,
in less than 20 minutes, that
handles an imaginary scenario.
Hopefully, it will
work, we'll see.
But, you can see
the power of API.AI
with a very small data
set, what it's able to do.
It's multi-lingual, it
already supports 40 languages,
and we're investing
in growing that.
We want it to be as
global as Google is.
There was a lot of
speculation last year
when we bought API.AI
that we will turn it
into sort of a closed
system that only
works with Google software.
The truth is, it's far from it.
API.AI works with all of the
different messaging platforms
that are out there.
And we're very proud of that.
We're a very open
company at Google,
we actually want you
to build the best
conversational applications that
work across all the platforms
that you're interested in.
And we want to keep
making API.AI the best
cross-platform tool.
So we're going to
continue to support
all of the platforms
that are out there.
I'm just going to go
through this very quickly,
but this is just an
example architecture
of how you can build a
conversational application.
So, on the left-hand
side, you can
see all of the
different channels
where conversations can come in.
So, it starts from owned
and operated websites
or web apps or mobile apps.
And you could have Google
Assistant properties
like Pixel, Aloe, and Home,
or you could have integrations
with the different applications
that I just showed you,
all of the different
messaging applications.
The other thing is you could
have voice calls come in
and be transcribed with Cloud
Speech API, and flown in.
All of those can get
processed by API.AI,
which handles the conversational
aspect, including context,
natural language
understanding, and figures
out how to involve the back-end.
And then, through
web hook integration,
you can connect it to
Google Cloud Platform
to handle all of your back-end
needs, or any other platform
that you want.
You can connect to other
external systems like ERP,
like CRM, or whatever
you need on the back-end.
You can get there through cloud
functions or any other Google
top-form application
cloud service.
OK, so now to the demo.
So what I'm going
to do now, we're
going to look at an imaginary
Google hardware store.
And we're going
to try and create
a conversational app
that processes requests
for that imaginary
store, including service
requests and commerce requests.
So we're going to just quickly
go through defining an entity,
defining the intent, adding
an ability to buy other items
through a WebHook,
and then we're
going to connect it to
a messaging platform.
OK, so let's switch
to the demo now.
OK, can everyone see my screen?
How's the font size?
Is it OK?
Yes.
People are saying yes.
OK, great.
OK, so let's start by
defining an entity.
And we'll list all
of the products
that we want to
sell in this store.
So let's say we want
to sell a Pixel.
And sometimes that is
called Google Pixel.
And it could also be
in plural, so let's say
Pixels and Google Pixels.
And let's say you also want to
sell a home, which could also
be Google Home.
And let's add the plural.
And let's add a
Chromecast to that.
Chromecasts.
And what else?
Let's add a Chromebook.
OK, and that's enough.
Let's save our entity.
And now let's define
our first intent.
So let's make the first
intent about service.
And let's just add
examples of how
users would ask for service.
So maybe one guy will say,
I'd like to fix my Pixel.
And you can see that
API.AI automatically
identified that Pixel
is one of the products
that I identified earlier and
it labeled it as a parameter
name called Products.
I'm just going to change it
to Product, because you just
want one product.
I'm going to save this.
And let's add a
few more examples.
Let's say, can I please
buy a Chromecast?
I'd like to get a Chrome.
Can I please-- oh, sorry.
I'm mixing commerce and service.
Let me redo this.
I'd like to fix my Pixel.
Can I please fix my Chromecast?
My Chromebook is not working.
And let's start with that.
And let's test it now.
So I'm going to
take this example,
but use a different product.
So instead of I'd
like to fix my Pixel,
let's try I'd like
to fix my Chromebook.
Oh, OK, so that's great.
So what you see is it identified
an intent that is service.
And it identified a
parameter name Product
that is Chromebook, which
is exactly what we wanted.
Now let's add a response.
Let's say, sure, no problem.
Dispatching service
for product right away.
Save.
And let's test it.
Can I please fix my Chromecast?
And you can see, it
says, sure, no problem.
Dispatching service from
Chromecast right away.
And if I click on
Show JSON, you can
see there's this very
rich JSON that you
can send to your back end,
to your application that
can actually process everything
that you need to do to actually
dispatch someone out there.
It's all structured information
that you can act on right away.
So this is great.
And we have something that
is doing service right now.
Let's also add a
Commerce intent.
And now let's say, I'd like to
buy three Chromecasts, please.
OK, so it identifies
quantity and product.
So let's name this
one as Quantity.
And instead of Products,
let's just call it Product.
And let's show a
few more examples.
So can I please get five Pixels?
OK, so this one, it
didn't auto recognize,
but we can easily fix that.
I'm going to remove this.
And instead, I'm going
to mark the 5 as Quantity
and pixels as Product.
And let's give it a
couple more examples.
Can I buy seven Chromebooks?
Please get me two Pixels.
OK, so it looks
like it's working.
Let's also add a
shipping address.
So let's say, can you please
send me four cool homes
to 5 Fifth Street,
New York, New York?
OK, so it recognized that
we have an address here.
It marked it.
Let's just show
it the full thing.
And then let's
just mark quantity.
And I'm going to save this.
And let's add a response.
Adding quantity, product,
and sending to address.
I think this one we don't need.
Let's delete it.
And let's save.
And let's test it out.
Let's say, can I
buy five Pixels?
OK, let me try, I'd like
to buy five Pixels, please.
OK, you can see the Intent,
it recognizes commerce.
It got that it's a Pixel.
It got that it's five.
And the address is
missing, obviously,
because I didn't
give an address.
And so it can't really
respond, because it
doesn't have an address.
But everything is working well.
Now, the previous
sentence I gave
should have been recognized,
but it wasn't recognized.
So this is where
API.AI really shines.
You can actually go in real
time and apply new training
based on the data, the
experiments you just made.
So this is what
we tried earlier.
Service for Chromebook.
That was correct.
So I can mark it as correct.
And please fix my Chromecast.
That also worked well earlier.
And this one did not work.
Can I buy five Pixels?
Oh, there was a
spelling mistake here.
Maybe that's why it didn't work.
But I can go back and actually
assign this training data
to what should have happened.
And I can say, this should
have been 5 quantity, not
unit length quantity.
And Pixel should
have been a product.
I can mark it with a checkmark.
And then from now on, it's going
to add that to the examples
it knows how to recognize.
And then this one
should be Commerce.
Quantity.
But I want to track this.
And Pixels is the product.
And checked.
I'm going to approve it.
And now let's try another one.
Let's try, can I buy
nine Chromecasts?
Great.
Recognize commerce.
Recognizes Chromecast.
Recognizes nine.
And now we see that it's
the same problem again,
that it doesn't have an
address, so it can't answer.
So this is something
really cool about API.AI.
You can very easily turn
this into a conversation
where if I mark these three
parameters as required,
I can now talk to
the user and ask
it to fill the required fields.
So if it's missing a
quantity, I can say,
how many would you like to buy?
And then for product, I can
ask, which product are you
interested in?
Notice that there's room
for multiple prompts.
This is because we
found that sometimes you
want to ask the same question
with multiple variations just
to make it more
interesting for users.
So let's also ask, where would
you like me to ship it to?
And let's save this.
And then let's try this again.
Can I buy seven Chromecasts?
OK, and so now you can
see it's responding.
It says, where would you
like me to ship it to?
And now I can tell it, 1
First Street, San Francisco,
California.
And then it responds,
adding seven Chromecasts
and sending it to
1 First Street,
San Francisco, California.
OK, this is all good
and pretty awesome.
Let's try one last one.
And then make this a
little bit more complex.
Let's try one that's
missing quantity.
So I'd like to buy a few Pixels.
Now, I never actually
trained it on a sentence
that looks like that.
If you look at the
other ones, there's
no place where I say a few.
But it already understands
that I want to do commerce.
Actually, it didn't get
the product this time.
We'll fix that in a second.
But I guess it's
because of the few.
How many would you like to buy?
Let's give it eight
Pixel And where would you
like me to ship it to?
7 Seventh Street, San
Francisco, California.
And now you can see it
finishes the full thing.
So we can go back on
training and just tell it
that if you have
something with few,
that still is a legitimate ask.
OK, so now let's make it a
little bit more interesting.
Now, let's say
that you want to be
able to feed this into
your back end application
into some sort of
a shopping cart
and be able to add
sort of multiple items
from the same kind.
So what I want to do here is
to have some sort of counter,
where I send this counter
to my back end, my back end
increments by one, and then
sends it back to API.AI
with an answer.
So the way I'm going
to do this is I'm
going to create what
we call a context.
So I'm going to create a
context called Shopping Cart.
And now every time someone
does a commerce operation,
it's going to save it
in the shopping cart.
And I'm going to create
another intent that requires
Shopping Cart as an input.
So this will now only happen
if someone has a shopping cart.
And let's say someone
says, please add one more
or I'd like to buy another
one or another one, please.
Let's call this Buyanother.
Buyanother.
And now let's add from
Shopping Cart, the product.
And let's add the quantity
and let's add the address.
So number and address and
shopping cart quantity
and shopping cart address.
OK, let's save.
Now, what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to connect it to my WebHook.
And if it doesn't
work, I'm just going
to put error, so that we
know that it didn't actually
go to the WebHook.
And I just want to show you
guys how that looks like.
So you can see,
this is a WebHook
I created in Cloud
Functions earlier.
That basically increments
one to a context
that comes from API.AI.
I can show you guys
the actual code.
It's basically four
or five lines of code.
That's all.
And no JS, by the way,
if someone's interested.
So let's try it out.
Let's see if it works.
So let's start by, I'd like
to buy a Chromebook, please.
Let's make it two
Chromebooks, please.
Where would you like
me to ship it to?
Let's say, 7 Seventh
Street, San Francisco.
So it's great.
It responds that it's adding
it to my shopping cart.
I get a context of
a shopping cart.
And now let's ask
it for another one.
And so you can see the response.
Adding one more
Chromebook, you now
have three in your
shopping cart.
And remember the context
of a conversation
that you have a Chromebook.
It's sent it to our back
end, the back end incremented
by one, sent it
back, and now you're
seeing the response at three.
If I try and trigger this
again, please add one more,
you'll see it says you now
have four in your shopping
cart of the Chromebooks.
So what you see here is
I didn't measure time,
but I think it's
something like 10,
15 minutes, we basically
built this whole conversation
application.
It does commerce.
It does service.
It'll get better the more
we add more examples to it,
the more it gets usage data,
and the more that we train it.
But it can already handle a
lot of queries pretty easily.
Now, what I would like to do
is I'm going to connect it here
to Facebook Messenger.
And you can see we have
one-click integrations.
Like, very easy
to start and stop.
Let's just start it.
And I'm going to go
to Facebook Messenger.
And now let's say, I'd like
to buy a Pixel, please.
Obviously, it's not working.
OK, perfect.
How many would you like to buy?
[APPLAUSE]
Go ahead and tell it six.
Thank you.
Let's give it an address.
6 6th Street, San
Francisco, California.
And now let's try
the last thing,
another one where it goes
directly to our WebHook.
OK, now you can
say it says seven.
So that's it, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you very much.
We got through this together.
You can see just how easy it
is to create a conversation
application that's
really powerful.
And with ease, you can
connect it automatically
to all of those cross-platform
applications you saw earlier.
You can put it on
your own website,
in your own mobile
app, or work through it
with the different messengers.
Very, very exciting.
So there'll be Q&A later.
But now I'd like to invite
to the stage Cornelius that
is going to show us
a little bit more
about what they've
done at Bosch.
CORNELIUS MUNZ: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
So thanks, Dan.
My name is Cornelius.
I'm working at Bosch
Thermotechnology.
We are Europe's leading OEM for
heating appliances, boilers,
appliances who prepare
hot water for you.
So can we switch
to the slide deck?
Slide disk.
OK, I go on.
OK, thanks.
OK, and our devices
become more and more
smarter the last years.
So we have now out of
the box IT connectivity
are built in in our devices.
Are if you sell a Bosch
appliance, a Bosch [INAUDIBLE],
you will get out of
the box AIPI support.
You can connect your app to
it and remote control it.
So that's fine.
But we have a problem.
We lose the contact more
and more to the customer.
So how get the interface
back to the customer
if the device becomes
more and more smarter?
And our approach
was that we tried
to figure out how our
conversational bots can
be used to keep in
contact to our devices.
And how does it work?
So we have had the answer
from a software architecture
perspective, many for layers.
On the left side, you
can see the interaction
of the user integrated in Skype,
Slack, Facebook Messenger,
whatever, your own home page.
And the user can send the
message to the API.AI chatbot.
That chatbot processes the
intent, as shown by Dan before,
and the intent detection
fires then a HTTP call
to the WebHook.
And the WebHook is now a piece
of software we have developed,
which maps the API.AI intent
to a domain-specific API call,
so which will call
to our boiler.
And the boiler
can, in that case,
set a new room temperature
setpoint to a new value,
respond with a HTTP, OK.
And then we can prepare
a fulfillment message
in our WebHook to respond
to the message of the user.
API.AI then routes
that message back
to the originated
messaging application.
And then it's done.
The boiler has set
a new temperature.
And hopefully, the
user [INAUDIBLE].
So let's have a
look on the demo.
So back to the demo.
So here I have a demo
set up on the left side.
You can see our internet portal,
which is already available.
So you can control
your heating appliance.
Can set some values, for
example, the current room
temperature setpoint,
the hot water setpoint
for your shower and bath.
And you can, for example,
prepare a holiday mode.
If you are leaving the home,
the device is going to stand by.
And you can save a lot
of money if the heating
device is switched off.
On the right side, I have
connected here my iPhone.
And Skype is opened.
And you see, like in the
demo before with the Facebook
Messenger, you have a
bot us a chat contact.
And then you can say, OK, for
example I will be on holiday.
And I have used Siri to transfer
speech to a chat message.
And then a required
parameter is missing.
To call the API of the boiler,
I need the date period.
And the bot asks me for that.
Next week.
I will send this next week.
And the magic in API.AI
transfers from then next week
in a date period, which could
be processed by our API.
And next week, hopefully, yeah.
it's transformed in a date.
And if our portal works fine,
that we have to refresh it.
Holiday mode is switched on
with the desired date period.
And we are done.
So use conversational--
[APPLAUSE]
--UX-- thanks-- to keep in
contact with your device.
And that's a good
possibility for us.
So let's dig a little bit
more into development issues.
How do we have done this?
It's the same setup we have
seen by [INAUDIBLE] before.
We have different
use cases, so we
can activate the holiday mode.
You can set or get
the auto temperature.
You can ask the boiler, if
you want to take a shower,
if the hot water is
prepared, and so on.
And you can set your schedule
of the boiler with buttons.
And yeah, that's fine.
But let's stick to the
activate holiday mode.
I have prepared
some [INAUDIBLE].
And yeah, then I
show this already.
And I want to
require a parameter.
It's the date period.
And then I have switched on
the WebHook for the [INAUDIBLE]
presentation.
And I want to use it here.
And now I take the
JSON here, which
is processed, and copy it out.
And then keep this in mind.
And now I switch to our
back end implementation.
Oh, my VM is switched off.
So let's be patient till
it's up and running.
So we are developing
our back ends .NET.
And we're using Visual
Studio for that.
And it was really easy
for us to use API.AI.
Oh, sorry for that.
Yeah, let's keep on talking.
Corporate networks are not
a good thing for developers.
OK, how to integrate
within a .NET solution.
I have a Web API
project up and running.
And the first thing I have to
do is I use the NuGet Package
Manager.
And I add the NuGet
package from API.AI.
So they provide many integration
SDKs for node, for JavaScript,
for everything.
So that's the first thing.
I added that NuGet package.
Then I prepare my controller.
Here you have the root
prefix of that controller,
which receives them.
The POST message here,
it's the POST annotation.
And you get a JSON body
out of that POST message.
And here, it's the model
from API SDK, which is
provided by the NuGet package.
And that model is
then in a form,
which you can process easily.
And here I have added
some if/else switches.
You can also use a
switch statement.
Doesn't matter.
And how to test it now
locally on your machine
before deploying it in the
cloud and connecting it directly
to the chatbot.
So I use here now the debug
mode locally on my laptop.
And use Postman or you can
use any other REST client.
Paste the JSON in you
have formerly copied out
of the API.AI console.
And then fire that
POST to the local host.
You can see it here.
It's now my local WebHook.
And [INAUDIBLE] back
to Visual Studio.
Hopefully, yeah, it holds on the
line where the activate holiday
mode intent is processed.
And the action name was
called activate holiday mode.
And now I have to read out the
parameter, so the date period.
And you have your
[INAUDIBLE] structure.
It's well-formed.
And you have the parameters.
And you see, OK,
yeah it's very small.
But you have one parameter.
It's named date period.
And it has that value.
And you can fetch
out that key value
pair out of that structure.
And then I call--
I have a API
Manager class, which
separates all our
domain-specific API away
from the controller.
Then I call the
set holiday mode,
activate it, and
activate the date period.
So that's the
domain-specific API call.
And then I prepare
the fulfillment.
And the fulfillment
is the response
of the chatbot to the user.
And here I do it mostly like
then before in the console.
I replace a placeholder
key with the date period
the user was expected.
And then I return OK.
So HTTP 200.
And if I go back to
the Postman, then you
can see here the fulfillment,
which is also JSON,
and which is sent back later on
if you deploy it to the cloud
through the API.AI chatbot.
And that's, overall, the
thing we have prepared.
We try to launch this
in the next two months
with the MBP approach.
So test it with a few users.
We are record what the
users say to the bot
to learn how we should
improve our utterances, which
fires the intent.
And then we are,
yeah, excited to see
the response of the users.
And we start to deploying it
not to Facebook and to Skype.
We start to adding that
chatbot to our internet portal,
so we have an interface, HTTP
interface through API.AI.
And then you can use it,
also, in your web portal.
So API.AI was really seamless.
It takes two or three
days to set it up
and running with
our real boilers.
I have to prepare that.
I switched off the
holiday mode later on.
Because my wife says, if
you come back and it's cold,
you're fired.
So we have out of the
box language support.
And that was really a
good language support,
even for European languages.
So we can use German as a
language, and Italian, French,
out of the box with API.AI.
Other solutions, that's not
fulfill that requirement.
And here we do not
have to translate
the speech with Google Translate
before sending it to API.AI.
We can directly use German
or Italian or French
as a language.
So thanks.
I would like to welcome Petr
from ING to show the next demo.
[APPLAUSE]
PETR NETUSIL: Thanks, Cornelius.
All right.
Excellent.
So my name is Petr Netusil.
I work in applied machine
learning department at ING.
Let me figure out
how this works.
Works good.
So there we get to experiment
with all sorts of fun
new stuff, like AI
machine learning NLP.
And I'm excited
to show you today
what we have been
building with API.AI.
And hopefully,
give you some tips
on how you can get
started yourself
and something on top of
what has been shown here.
But well, first,
ING, big global bank.
But actually, my
boss has recently
realized we're not
a bank anymore.
We are an IT company in
a financial industry.
And as an engineer,
I find it excellent.
I find that transition great.
And good thing they also
didn't just said it like that,
but they invested almost
a billion dollars,
if I calculate-ish correctly,
into digital transformation
to make that happen
and to make sure
that we are on the platform
as our clients are as well.
But anyway, let's go to
the deep, gory details
of the solution.
So this is our architecture.
And maybe good to know,
this is also our bot.
It's Marie, our
digital assistant.
So she can help you with
everything about the card.
So that is the kind of domain
we have selected for a pilot.
And what you see
perhaps immediately
is that the
architecture's different.
So normally, the
traditional architectures
would talk to API.AI directly
and then do some WebHook
fulfillments out of that.
But we said, no, no, no, we
want control, we want security,
we want logging, we
want to do it better.
So we actually place
our conversation logic
in the middle.
So I'll fly you
through how this works.
So you start from any channel,
Facebook Messenger, Skype,
or some other channel.
And then you go into
the conversation logic
that will basically route
with all these different APIs.
So if it's just API.AI
discussion, you talk to API.AI.
So everything, again, happens
via some REST calls, HTTPS
[INAUDIBLE] requests,
like you have seen before,
or you can route the sentiment
analysis, which is something
I'm going to show you.
And we are very
excited about too.
So that's based on the
Google Natural Language API.
We also built a sentiment
analysis and intervention
dashboard, which is
based on WebSocket.
So you have a real time kind of
connection between the server
and the client.
We have also Twilio
for authentication.
And lastly, and for us at
least more importantly,
we hooked it up
all to our ING APIs
and we will get live data
from this moving forward.
So if my corporate
laptop will work
and we can very
kindly switch to it.
[LAPTOP BELL]
We have even the sound.
Very good.
[INAUDIBLE] number.
Oh, we're perfect.
So Marie, our bot, well,
let's just start with her.
So what she will ask
you immediately is,
you can get started about
questions and requests
about ING cards.
Now, typically what we
see in Belgium a lot is
that a lot of people are
just calling us, like, hey,
I don't know where is my card?
And we get lots of these calls.
So they would ask, hey,
I ordered it last week.
And now it's not it's
not there anymore.
And did you send it?
Did you not send it?
So one incidence
we have programmed
is, where is my card?
And Marie, what she'll try to
do now is to authenticate me.
Because we don't want just
everyone to know these details.
So our demo profile Robert
has born on 1st of May 1967.
Now, what happens is we're
going to match the user uniquely
based on the first name,
surname, and the birth date
and get a one-time
verification token.
Whew, yes, we got it.
The demo gods are with us today.
And I can put something grand
on [INAUDIBLE] it won't work.
But let's be nice to Marie
and put the right one.
So it's 129335.
Right.
So what happens now,
we get authenticated
for the next 10 minutes.
So you don't need to push
these tokens back and forth
all the time.
And we get the right
delivery address details.
So this is one of the use
cases I wanted to show you.
But the thing is
we are extremely
excited about bots ourselves,
but maybe not everyone is.
They are still young and
they're still learning.
And what will theoretical
happen or more practically
is that someone dislikes it.
So saying, I know
this bot is terrible.
My god!
[HORN BLOWING FAILURE]
What is that?
Oh, so it's our sentiment
analysis dashboards
are triggering that.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
If you have ideas
for a better sound,
please talk to me
after the session.
Right.
So this is basically
the web circuit
I was talking to you about.
So there is this server
to client integration,
which triggered that.
So let me deal with it.
So here you see transcripts
or, well, a dashboard
of all the different sessions
today or now is just the one.
And you see the different
sentiment, which is happening.
But what is interesting
here is that I can actually
go inside that full
chat transcript.
I see everything here.
And I can boss the bot.
So what I'm going
to do, I'm going
to stop Marie and just
start the conversation as
if I would be someone
controlling and managing
that online conversation.
So hi, this is someone alive.
I want to get out.
You know, it's going to
be a little bit silly now,
because I'm going to have
that conversation with myself.
But the point is API.AI
is responding now.
And I have a full control
of what is happening, OK?
So you see that point.
Now, to satisfy the
development and coding people
amongst yourselves,
let's actually
see how ridiculously simply you
can implement this yourself.
So our conversation logic
is built on node.js.
And this is how you can
require the Google NPM package.
So hopefully, you will use
this commented line and not
this hacked way, which
we used over here.
And then you just call a method
that is the detection method.
And you wait for a callback.
And you get a callback
back after some time.
And then you do whatever you
want with that sentiment value.
So it's extremely simple.
And I think the guys at Google
done a great job with that one.
Right.
Let's go to the API.AI and
how we implemented this.
So what I wanted
to show you and how
we used to trigger the
conversational logic
is like this.
So say, where is my
card or something else.
The JSON line you are
interested in is this one.
So there is an action.
And just using that action, you
can program anything manually
for fulfillments for further on.
But what is maybe
more interesting here,
and I'm going to take you
to our development Marie,
is that once your bots are
going to be scaled further
and you are going to build
a lot of different intents
and conversations,
it will get messy.
It will be back and forth.
And people will not just
follow the preprogrammed line.
So you want to be
able to still navigate
within that conversation.
Now, one of the ways we
found, at least for ourselves,
how you can do that in
API.AI is to create, first,
some kind of a
naming convention,
because otherwise
it's a big mess.
And understand that
for one use case,
there is actually many
intents which you can use.
So say there is a use
case activate card,
but one kind of a use
case is more intents
which you want to trigger.
So we're going to
start the first intent
and then pass this context
up until the last one.
So let's see how it looks.
So you see that the first intent
has no input context, but just
the output context.
And then you want to pass
those along the conversation.
Here are the [INAUDIBLE].
Typically, you would put
hundreds of them, which we
have in our to-be-live version.
And then what is
also interesting
here is managing
the conversation.
So here we put the response
without a parameter and here
with a parameter.
And only if you have the
parameter, as Dan showed you
before, it will be triggered.
All right.
So I hope you guys
liked our little demo.
I'm very happy to connect with
you during the conference.
And yeah, thank
you for watching.
[APPLAUSE]
So we're going to
have a bit of a Q&A.
So I'd like to call Cornelius
and Dan back to the stage.
And, well, fire away.
And the nice guys who
were there asked us
if you can come back to the mic,
so that everyone can hear you.
DAN AHARON: We can probably
switch back to the slides,
I guess.
PETR NETUSIL: Yeah.
Questions.
DAN AHARON: If anyone has
a question, please, yeah,
come up to the mic.
PETR NETUSIL: Yeah, or
just shout very loud.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the great demo.
One question is, what do
you do about analytics?
You say the API.AI
is a complete system.
I didn't see any analytics link.
DAN AHARON: Yeah,
that's a great question.
So we don't have any analytics
built into API.AI right now.
There's a bunch of other
vendors that we work
with that provide analytics.
If you connect with
me offline, I'm
happy to recommend a few to you.
PETR NETUSIL: Well, the way we
approach it, we lock everything
and we have our data
scientists get crazy on it.
So maybe that's a way
how you can do that too.
AUDIENCE: And sorry,
question for you.
You saw you interrupted
the Facebook conversation
and had a manual intercept.
How did you do that?
PETR NETUSIL: Manual
intercept of what?
AUDIENCE: The conversation.
You sort of had a
manual intercept
into the bot conversation.
How did that work?
PETR NETUSIL: So
it's in node.js.
But I've said that there is
a global parameter for all
the sessions you can set up,
whether it's POST or not,
and then you manage
manage it based on that.
So I can show you later
on, if you want, in detail.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
Thanks.
PETR NETUSIL: Anyone else?
CORNELIUS MUNZ: Hey, come on up.
PETR NETUSIL: There
is actually a line.
That's great.
AUDIENCE: I have a
couple of questions.
The first one is
regardless [INAUDIBLE]
figure out the intent.
Can I have two
intents [INAUDIBLE]
technically take the
same number of entities?
And how does it figure it out?
Let's say that I
have one intent that
is supposed to act on a negative
set of words and the other one
acts on positive.
DAN AHARON: Yeah.
So it learns by language.
So if you set up the intent with
examples of negative sentences
and a set of entities, and
then a different intent that
has positive sentences and
even the same entities,
API.AI knows how to figure
out which intent to choose
according to your examples.
AUDIENCE: And can you load
the entities from, let's say,
a transactional table
that you are continuously
updating all day long?
DAN AHARON: Yes.
Yes, you can import
or export from the UI.
And also, there's
a full back end API
that you can access
everything programmatically,
which we didn't show today.
But it's all documented
on the website.
AUDIENCE: And does that require
retraining every time there's
a new entity on that table?
DAN AHARON: Yes, but the
training happens very quickly.
In fact, the model was trained
multiple times during my demo.
It happened in the background
and you didn't even notice.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
DAN AHARON: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Awesome demo.
Thanks, guys.
PETR NETUSIL: Some
[INAUDIBLE] here.
AUDIENCE: I had a question on
the difference between the toy
applications and when
you went to production.
It seems like you'd have
common [INAUDIBLE] explosion
in Natural Language.
And how did you handle that?
You said you had hundreds
of the templates up there.
PETR NETUSIL: So we
are not live yet.
We will be live in a few months.
But the way we have
approached it is we
have lots of user sessions.
And we basically had
people coming out
and say, just tell me, how
would you ask this question?
And we have, yeah, I
think we have hundreds
and hundreds of-- you know,
just per one small intent,
hundreds and hundreds
of utterances
programmed over there.
Try to get a trend.
I think it's easy
and fun to do a bot,
but it's difficult
to do it right.
So this is one of the
parts where, yeah, you
need to do it right.
DAN AHARON: If
you're interested,
you should check out
the third session, which
is about actions on Google
and talking about how to build
conversational actions.
They're going to talk
a lot about lessons
of how to build a right bot and
right conversational interfaces
that think about all those
different expressions.
One thing we see
a lot of people do
is use cards and buttons,
which sort of help
simplify the experience
for some users.
But make that optional.
So give the users the
option of whether they
want to use the cards
or whether they want
to type in Natural Language.
AUDIENCE: Would the semantic
analysis help in that regard?
DAN AHARON: Yeah, yeah,
some users love to type.
And they want to express
themselves that way,
while others just want
the fastest way of getting
things done, right?
So you give them both.
And then they pick
whatever they want.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAN AHARON: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm not sure I know how to
ask this question right.
But every demo that I've
ever seen on conversation
relies always one-on-one.
What about the bot being kind
of a moderator of a conversation
between multiple people?
DAN AHARON: Good question.
So the way that
it's structured is
it's built on a conversation.
And it has, as context, all
of the prior conversation
that happened.
So if you have a conversation
with multiple people and one
bot, then as long
as your intention is
for it to remember what
everyone else is saying,
then you're good to go.
Then it doesn't change
anything in the logic.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, like if you
were trying to figure out, hey,
we're going out for dinner and
here are five different places
we want to go--
DAN AHARON: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: --that sort of thing.
DAN AHARON: Right,
like Google Assistant--
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
DAN AHARON: --and
Google [INAUDIBLE].
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah.
All right, thank you.
DAN AHARON: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hello.
Great talk.
Great demo.
DAN AHARON: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I liked
that question too.
I guess, two things.
One, are there push
notifications with this yet?
Could you set something that
eventually the chat will just
chime in when a counter goes
off or you set a reminder?
DAN AHARON: So I don't think so.
But let me get back to you.
Are we back to the slides?
OK.
Send me an email.
And I'll get back to you.
PETR NETUSIL: The way you
can solve this is actually
to trigger it--
at least in our
case, to trigger it
from your conversational logic.
So that's why we put our
thing in the middle to say,
hey, psshht, let's fire
up a push notification.
AUDIENCE: So you
would say like, show
me the status or something,
and then you would get back?
Is that what you're saying?
PETR NETUSIL: It's from an
application side, not from API
directly.
AUDIENCE: Oh, I got you.
Yeah.
And a quick question
about deployment.
So you had a dev
environment and production,
would you just
edit the interface
or do you version control that?
PETR NETUSIL: Good question.
DAN AHARON: Cornelius?
PETR NETUSIL: Oh,
Cornelius [INAUDIBLE].
CORNELIUS MUNZ: I
didn't get it right.
So can you repeat it?
AUDIENCE: Oh, so you had a
dev environment and prod,
do you version control
the configurations?
How would you deploy
your dev to prod?
CORNELIUS MUNZ: Yeah, we have
version control or we use Git.
We have different environments,
staging, testing, and stuff.
And yeah, it's a continuous
integration environment.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
PETR NETUSIL: So I think there's
version control many levels.
On the code, we use Git, like
any other person in the world.
But for API.AI directly, we
just created different bots.
And what you can do is
just extract one bot.
Just export everything
there is and just
import it in another bot.
CORNELIUS MUNZ: So it can
export as [INAUDIBLE] file.
PETR NETUSIL: It's
export/import.
CORNELIUS MUNZ: So all--
PETR NETUSIL: [INAUDIBLE]
CORNELIUS MUNZ:
--yeah, configuration
of the bot itself, not your
code, so I didn't get it.
So the configuration of the bot
can be exported as a zip file.
And you can store
it safe within--
and you can import it later
on with intents, entities,
contexts all available.
AUDIENCE: Oh, perfect.
CORNELIUS MUNZ: And at
the end, it's a JSON file.
AUDIENCE: Oh, cool.
All right, thank you.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PETR NETUSIL: Manual.
Yeah.
CORNELIUS MUNZ: Manual.
AUDIENCE: So one of
your early slides
showed Cortana and Alexa.
DAN AHARON: Right.
AUDIENCE: Is it trivial
for me to create
a bot that then interacts with
Google Home, Alexa, Cortana,
a trivial connection?
DAN AHARON: Yeah,
so their interfaces
are slightly different, right?
And so the data that they send
to other applications and back,
the format is a
little different.
But we've built our
connectors to try and minimize
that sort of interruption
as much as possible,
so that our developers can focus
on the actual conversational
logic.
So for the most part,
you can build one logic
and connect it to
multiple connectors.
AUDIENCE: It'll connect
DAN AHARON: Yeah.
Now, the caveat is when
you're talking to Google Home
by voice versus
if you're texting
on Google Allo or
Facebook Messenger,
the users speak sometimes
in a different way,
use different words.
And the way you want to talk
back to them is also different.
Like on a chat, you might want
to show them cards with a map
or maybe you want to write
a long paragraph of text.
When you're reading
back on Google Home,
you don't want to read back
a long paragraph of text,
because users will
get bored, right?
So you actually
may want to build
different conversational
experiences for each one.
But if you wanted to create a
single experience, you could.
CORNELIUS MUNZ: And from
a technical point of view,
you have to make a trust
relation between Facebook
and API.AI.
And you would generate an
API key on Facebook or Skype
or whatever and copy that API
key into the API.AI console.
And that's all so a
trust relation is there.
And then Skype
can talk to API.AI
and respond to that message.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
Thank you, both.
DAN AHARON: OK,
two minutes left.
So maybe one or two questions.
AUDIENCE: Good afternoon.
I was trying to build a
toy project the other day.
You each use your building
address, street address entity.
I noticed that in
our test data, there
is certain address that's
a rather unusual construct.
Never get recognized.
So add those to
the training data.
But it just doesn't
seem correct that.
So what we recommend developer
to do for a situation like this
is when the black box fails.
DAN AHARON: Yeah, so
it might be a bug.
So I would go--
we have a community forum.
I would report it in
the community forum.
And we can look into it
and see if it's a bug.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
DAN AHARON: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, so
my first question
is, is there a way to
resume a conversation
or it's all within
one conversation?
DAN AHARON: So that
was on yours, right?
PETR NETUSIL: Yeah, it could be.
So if you mean the
bot boss, you can just
flip it back and forth.
So as an agent, you
have full control.
You can just start it,
stop it whenever you like.
And secondly, every session we
have with a bot is in memory.
So we remember everything
you did, you said,
and all the context
you have had.
So you resume
anytime you'd like.
AUDIENCE: OK, cool.
And then more about the
development life cycle.
You said we can export or
import the configuration.
What about, is the training
data part of the configuration?
PETR NETUSIL: Yeah, all the
utterances, like the hundreds
I was talking about, is that.
AUDIENCE: And OK,
just to confirm,
the last question is,
what level of certainty,
giving a certain training
data will the response
will be always the same?
Or it's behind the
scene we don't know?
DAN AHARON: So it's machine
learning-based, right?
So the more training
data you give it,
every time you
give it more data,
it could change the
potential answer.
But we do give a confidence
score with the results,
so you can see sort
of [INAUDIBLE].
CORNELIUS MUNZ: It's
part of [INAUDIBLE].
And you can see the confidence
level, it's 80%, 90%, or lower.
And you can decide by your own,
if it is lower, to give a--
DAN AHARON: We're at time.
But thank you, everyone,
so much for coming.
PETR NETUSIL: Thank you.
DAN AHARON: This has been great.
And have a great rest
of Google Cloud Next.
Thanks, Petr, Cornelius.